our guest today is craig modd craig is a
writer photographer author publisher as
well as designer and developer at
flipboard inc in palo alto california
craig's interests include the future of
publishing and storytelling which
consists of his own work artspace tokyo
a publication that he co-authored
designed and published using the
crowdfunding platform kickstarter
raising close to 24 000.
in 30 days his goal was 15 000 so he
exceeded that for the reprinting and the
ipad version yep art space tokyo is a
personal guide and interpreter
connecting the reader with the
neighborhoods and figures behind some of
the most inspiring art spaces in tokyo
he is also co-founding editor and
engineer behind to put dot com a
socially generated newspaper for geeks
designers and venture capitalists hope i
said that right
sorry just getting going craig is also
known as the guy who wrote that ipad
article entitled books
in the age of the ipad print is dying
digital is surging and everyone is
confused craig is quoted from the front
of his site craigmod.com as saying
books are systems we're in the middle of
a publishing shakedown and i'm just
trying to make sense of it please
welcome to film courage via skype mr
craig mott hello craig hello guys hello
looking forward to this for some time
now yes we're just excited to be
connected with you here we're awesome
i'm excited to share you with our
audience i guess you could say love it
well i'm excited to be here thank you um
thank you for having me craig where did
you grow up and where did you go to
school i grew up in um actually
connecticut
um
sort of in a
working-class town
um of which nobody knows
those things exist in connecticut
you know it's uh you sort of grow up in
this
sort of bubble there and i remember when
i left connecticut and then i had this
sort of removed perspective on what the
rest of the world sees connecticut as
it was a huge shock um which was very
fascinating uh the whole pipe smoking
yacht sailing um
version of that uh of the state actually
i never i never really engaged much with
um so that was that was very interesting
but um i grew up in connecticut and then
i uh i went to school
for
uh two years in tokyo
at wasada university
doing a one-year intensive language
studies uh study abroad program and
doing one year of
just a language sort of post-grad
intensive program and i also
studied at the university of
pennsylvania in the digital media design
program
which is sort of this
uh mushing between computer science and
fine arts
and um my fine arts focus actually
uh at upenn was
on photography and covering you know the
years that you spent you know i believe
10 years in tokyo
what is it about japan that that
fascinates you tell us about your your
love affair with japan
uh it was it was uh
it's interesting um it's it's kind of
one of those
uh it's one of those countries that you
know it almost feels like it shouldn't
exist
um you know especially tokyo you have
this massive city one of the biggest
cities in the world
and
it doesn't really operate like any other
city that i've been to
um especially
regarding um crime which
is
really fascinating uh there's just no
you you especially i was just in brazil
two weeks ago i was in sao paulo
in rio and i was um
i was actually on the beach at about
three in the morning
just watching the waves
on copacabana
and a little kid came over to me and
tried to steal my watch wow um
which is just kind of uh you know it's
just sort of ridiculous um and while we
were in brazil all these kind of bizarre
things happened and there's definitely
this sense of um
you know you have to be
vigilant about protecting yourself in
some ways
which after leaving in tokyo for so long
because there is none of that in tokyo
tokyo is a city that
there's
very little petty crime um i've never
heard of anyone ever getting
held up uh
you know there's no i've never seen a
gun
uh there's very little drug uh sort of
movement in in the city
um there's just it's very uh for city of
so many people that are all
packed so closely together you'd think
that there'd be more
um
violence or you think there'd be more
crime and there really there isn't you
could tape 100 bills to your your shirt
and walk around at four in the morning
and
nothing would happen you can walk
anywhere in the city um
so
you know and that's not something i
expected when i went there
and i think that it's also not something
you see immediately it's not something
you're totally aware of immediately
but if you're
if you're like me and you like exploring
cities then
what that means is just the whole city
is open to you to explore whenever you
want
and so
you know japan is a country it's a it's
a culture with a lot of
uh walls
and um it requires an investment of time
to to kind of like start to break down
those walls and to sort of dig deeper
into the culture
and so
i went when i was 19 and i had a lot of
time to study and i was able to
really get into the language and
by the end of that first year
i had hitchhiked i'd spent a month
hitchhiking across the country
and which is a great way to improve your
language every day you're sort of
introducing yourself to people um you're
going through
sort of a really well-defined set of
greetings and so i came out of that
hitchhiking experience and by the end of
the first year i could communicate
fairly well and it just became an
addiction kind of digging deeper into
that into that culture the more you
learned about uh communication uh sort
of the
the deeper and the quicker you'd be
allowed to go uh into the culture and
that i think that's what really
you know over the last you know i was
there from basically age 19
to 29 with a little bit of a break in
between um but during that period i
think that's what that's what really uh
captured my my uh
my interest the most um aside from the
fact obviously that japanese aesthetics
uh all of my design work is sort of
completely informed by japanese
aesthetics and the sense of space and
um you know the the use of uh
sort of nuance uh in typography
and balance
um you know graphic artists uh like
kenya hara um
you know and and sort of a lot of the
magazine work over there aside from from
being captured by that was really there
was really this addiction to digging
into the culture it was really
fascinating now you mentioned in an
interview that while you were in japan
you lived very cheaply in a room close
to a size of a closet i believe
and you said you were able to save a lot
of money and keep your overhead low
and then when you came to the bay area
you knew you wanted to work on projects
of your choice so you had this reserve
so to speak to fall back on can you talk
about the practicality of saving up and
being able to live frugally in order to
spend more time on creativity
i think it's uh it's it's so it's so
important especially
um right out of university right you
know if you're a recent grad
um you know i i i moved to tokyo the
kind of the interesting thing about
tokyo is that actually you can you can
live extremely cheaply there
um
much more so than i think in a city like
new york
which would require almost like double
the amount of of money i'm my apartment
in tokyo
cost
about it was about 600 a month which is
not that expensive
it was small and it was a little bit
older and that's kind of the great thing
about japan is that if you're okay with
older um then you can find really good
deals on things
and so i was living effectively in sort
of like the soho of tokyo and i actually
i still have that apartment over there
that's i'm subletting right now but um
you know 600 a month in effectively in
the center of
soho you can bike everywhere uh there's
lots of great food that you can get for
ten dollars a meal and you can eat
wonderful fish and and you know these
really kind of delicious meals so the
cost of living is extremely can be
extremely low in a city like tokyo of
course the other extreme is there too
and if you want to spend
thirty thousand dollars a month uh on an
apartment there's apartments easily for
thirty thousand dollars a month i mean
in my neighborhood this is kind of the
fascinating thing about that city too is
that my apartment was six hundred
dollars a month and then
two buildings down for me the apartments
were selling for
uh it's about a thousand square meters
and it was i think it was about 2.3
million dollars
um so there is that there's this you
know there's this massive uh
uh sort of gamut there but um
yeah no i mean my
my interest had always been kind of um
i don't know fulfilling these or
listening to these creative impulses
you know and i think anyone who's
uh especially you know filmmakers uh you
know uh
writers
you kind of feel this energy that keeps
you awake at night um that'll wake you
up in the middle of the night and if
it's sort of this
um i don't know it comes from a place
within like you know within yourself but
it feels sort of ethereal and you know
like this divination of some sort of um
um
some sort of
inspiration through spirit but you know
listening to this thing is what i've
tried to do for
most of my 20s and so
if you're able to minimize the cost of
living
but you can still be in a city like
tokyo which is incredibly inspiring and
rich and and
such an amazing uh
sort of environment to be in especially
when you're when you're in your early
twenties
um if you can find a way to do that i
think it's a very powerful thing
um and so i had spent my 20s kind of
listening to that voice
and working on projects without
being overly concerned with
what's the return going to be on this
how much money is this going to make
um
and then at the same time thankfully
having a computer science background and
being able to do web
related consulting i was able to do
you know one or two small consulting
jobs a year that would effectively pay
for my cost of living for the year
and then be able to work on
the books
the book projects or the um the
publishing projects or the web projects
or the storytelling projects that
um i think for me as a creator
it was it was an extremely important
period of of time to understand the
creative process
and um understand how to believe in that
sort of that voice or that feeling that
you feel uh that that'll wake you up in
the middle of the night so not being so
concerned was from some of the trappings
of success that i know la people fall
into that i'm sure the bay area as well
where you kind of have to have the nice
car and it's the right neighborhood and
then you get stuck in that lifestyle and
you kind of can't get out right let's
switch to your online content for a
moment now you have so much when you do
your name there so much comes up whether
it be interviews articles your journal
as you call it at craigmod.com
and you appear to have an intense focus
a passion and a keen intuition it seems
and it appears that a combination of
this add up to rising above the crowd in
most industries
um in making a name for yourself how
much have you approached the media and
how much have they come to you good
question um
it's uh
i think i mean it's you know the
internet is in a lot of ways just you
know whoever can allow the you know yell
the loudest um
uh you know who can who can
yell the loudest the all the prettiest
um and hopefully have something
insightful to say in there um
you know i
i think i was largely
totally completely not on any any maps
aside from
a few
kind of design
design circles uh very small
um
uh sort of publishing circle radars
uh up until about a year and a half ago
and um
i don't know i had reached this point i
was 27 turning 28
and
i had reached this point where i felt
like i had been kind of
holding my breath as i was working
if that makes sense
where
i'd kind of been dancing or tiptoeing
around a lot of things i wanted to say
or wanted to work on and i was like all
right you know this is re this is this
is silly let's let's uh
let's let's dive into one thing let's
let's let's create the space and the
time
um to just really go for go for it on
one thing and so i went to you know i
did that trip to nepal which was
really spur of the moment um
and uh completely uh
an unexpected experience on on every
level i went to nepal i did that
experience i came back
and uh i had i had this you know really
fun time with this k with the camera
with the gf1 the panasonic gf1
and i'd also had a great time with you
know on on that trip and i wanted to
um
i'm sure filmmakers have this this
problem and photographers have this
problem where you you kind of create
this body of work that's private and
that
to edit it and put it out there it's
like you need to have some sort of uh
milestone or some sort of deadline that
you need to hit
and i really wanted to take the photos
from that trip in the store part of the
story from that trip
and
create something out of that
but i didn't really have a good
framework for it i didn't want it to
just be
the photos or just the story and so i
framed it around that uh camera
review slash travelogue
so it's like part technical really
technical review but also kind of this
um pico hire style you know
description of you know what was
happening while i was up in the
mountains
um and that
i had i had zero um
um
i had i really didn't expect that to do
uh nearly as well as it did um and i
remember that the day i posted that i
had people emailing me just saying
you know friends in the publishing
industry saying why did you you know why
did you
publish that on your site for free
that's silly you know that you know you
could have sold that to a magazine and
made more money or
and um it just you know it was
i didn't expect anything to come from it
but
um i was very lucky i
um
you know i emailed a lot of
people a lot of big bloggers
john gruber
i was really kind enough to
sort of
highlight that on his site this post and
i think that that helped set off a chain
reaction of
getting picked up in a lot of other
pieces of media
and so that that did really well and
that kind of
i think
started the ball rolling you know what i
mean i i i
i think that was my first
exposure beyond kind of these extremely
small niche
circles
and um you know it's interesting once
that happens you can kind of
start to build on that momentum
but you know the fact of the matter is
is i spent
on that article
i spent you know 150 hours
putting that article together i mean
between the the the photo editing the
writing uh the editing of the writing
the rewriting um the design sort of
building those templates for my site um
prepping to do kind of media blasts to
to bloggers um it was it was an it was
an insane amount of work it was it was
an insane insane amount of work um
so really if that i think if that
article hadn't done well i i don't know
if i would have done
uh the follow-ups to it or if i would
have done books in the age of the ipad
or embracing the digital book or if i
would have done the kickstarter campaign
um but that article and the response to
that article really i think was the
momentum that
gave me the confidence to say okay if
you invest 100 hours 150 hours you know
into
into an article or into a piece or into
some sort of creative output that you're
kind of you're you're listening to that
voice
that's keeping you up at night to
produce this thing
and
you you believe in it and
you you don't just
kind of uh you don't just create it and
hope it does well but you create it and
you you massage it and you you sculpt it
and you polish it and you find that
balance between being overly precious
with it because you can polish
forever
and never release it um you know it can
become your chinese democracy and
you know finding that balance between
polishing and understanding when it's
when you've done as much as you can when
you've brought it to that point that it
should be made public uh and then
actually having the guts to
to put it out there i mean that's
the closer you get to publishing
something like that or the closer you
get to producing
um
uh
you know producing that thing that
uh is your dream i guess in in some ways
producing a piece like that for me was
really a dream come true and you know
coelho and you know the alchemist and
you know his his writing he he
speaks very frequently about
you know the closer you become to the
things that you love the more you kind
of push away from it or the more fearful
you become
um
so it's kind of
believing in in
believing in the potential for the the
out the outcome to be good uh believing
in in the response believing in
the connection that that piece is going
to have with people
finding that balance when you're working
on on projects like that i think is
really important but to get back to your
your your question about the media
you know i
like i said i mean with all of these
things and in the kickstarter write-up
about art space tokyo i i try to speak
to this
um pretty strongly is that you really do
have to you have to tailor um you know
you don't just put something out there
and hope people find it you
go out there you do research you target
the bloggers the journalists that have
written about things that are that are
aligned with the piece that you're doing
and you you
speak to them directly and you speak to
them very succinctly too you know only a
couple of a couple sentence couple
sentences in an email is really all you
need with a link um so there was there
was a tremendous amount of work there
and then i was very lucky to get to get
a positive response and to be able to
build off that positive media response
kind of as a
self-perpetuating sort of
some somewhat of an echo chamber i guess
you know and speaking of your work craig
you know
you know your site you know
craigmod.com is you know it's simple
it's beautiful it's elegant um you know
and and i love a lot of i love the way
you sort of lay it out in your design
and how much work you put into it it
just makes me wonder how much time do
you spend on sort of the design
and layout of what you do
in comparison to the actual content
itself
it's always a back and forth so for
example let me i guess i can explain
like how how i do
one of those essays like the the gf1
article or books in the age of the ipad
um i'll start by writing in in i
actually use pages and i've pages set up
with
a couple of templates you know to make
the typography a lot nicer and just
write in full screen mode on pages and
i'll like drag
a couple of sort of dummy images in to
the text as i'm writing um
to kind of like remember okay i want an
illustration here or you know be great
to have a photo here or whatever
and um and then i'll take that raw text
kind of unedited and then i'll start
doing uh html layout around that
and i'll start
kind of doing this this
dance between
um getting the typography right
finding the right form for that uh for
the text and then also editing the text
and sort of printing it out and taking a
macro view at it and how should it be
rearranged and kind of
going back and forth between uh playing
with the design massaging the design
bringing in the illustrations are
bringing the photography
and then doing more rewrites and more
editing on the uh on the text itself
it's really i mean it's it's a very kind
of
organic
sort of uh collaboration there between
uh design design and and writing for me
and just going back real quickly to your
journal posts and you know how many
comments you get because there's just
there's just hundreds uh and aside from
going to bloggers about it what else do
you do in order to sort of spread your
content
not so much i mean you know these these
things kind of be they take on a life of
their own after a certain you know
there's there's a gladwellian like
tipping point
um where suddenly
you know you are if anyone searches for
uh ipad
and book you know you're like in the top
10 google you know results for that
um you know and like for that that that
camera review i mean you search for that
camera and it's like the you know that
article is one of the top results which
i think i think is really interesting
because it's just it's a great
manifestation of you know if you create
genuinely useful nourishing content um
that people respond to and people are
willing to link to and people talk about
conversation develops around that
then google is going to recognize that
as being
a really critical cornerstone in the
discussion around that topic
um which is cool because i mean it's
it's you know that whole google ranking
you know you know how do you do seo
optimization it's it's somewhat of a
black art and
to actually put zero effort into that
optimization um but to just see
those pieces kind of be picked picked up
as
like i said cornerstones in the eyes of
google is very cool and i mean like tons
of i'd say 40 of my traffic probably
comes from
actually google searches now you
mentioned in an article with the japan
times that authors will choose a certain
publisher because they know that that
publisher will uh you know possibly
tweet their followers and that will
generate into thousands of sales so in
light of this and faced with the
possibility of art space tokyo not being
reprinted or being reprinted but in a
reduced form you decided to buy back the
distribution rights from the publisher
and tap into social media to raise funds
um through kickstarter to reprint print
yourself so is this something that you
really had to wrestle with in terms of
your own decision or just sort of a gut
reaction you knew this is exactly what i
need to do
no i i wanted to do that since the
moment i heard of kickstarter i think it
was um
probably
fall of oh nine i think when i first saw
kickstarter
and i just immediately emailed them and
said hey i have this project i want to
reprint this book
um and that was back when you had to
kind of
i mean you really had to pitch your idea
to them it was still a very closed
community and um
it was great they're very responsive and
um
sorry to interrupt did you know yancey
strickler no no i didn't know anyone
there uh i was aware of uh andy bio wax
pancake um who i know he had some i
forget his exact involvement with with
the site um early on but i know i
remember him speaking about it
frequently and i think that's actually
who i
who turned me on to it um but i didn't
know anyone there i was just emailing
out of the blue
um
but i didn't get a chance the
negotiations to buy back the rights took
a while
and i was kind of you know i was
traveling and then i was writing the gf
one piece and then uh i started doing
some speaking in tokyo and so it was
like a very kind of a busy winter and
then um yeah things sort of aligned and
after books in the age of the ipad uh my
i had this sort of momentum and i
thought okay this is a good time to kind
of try to capture this momentum and um
you know it's funny because you go you
wonder alright i have at that time it
was like six thousand twitter followers
and you go you know what are six
thousand twitter followers worth you
know
it's hard to it's hard to sort of
monetize that yeah or to put a number on
it and uh
it was kind of funny you know doing this
campaign you're like okay well you know
they're worth at least 25 000
um which is kind of cool to see that
but um i mean speaking of that and
placing a value on sort of social media
if there was one social media platform
that anyone listening
should be on for their business which
one would you choose and why
i mean
for me
you know twitter has worked really well
um
i i haven't uh you know i've played a
little bit with facebook with their
pages and their groups
but um
facebook for me as an advertiser
actually was fantastic that experience
of selling arts based tokyo through um
facebook ads um
it's fascinating i mean facebook
their valuation i think is
probably grossly low when you actually
if you go in there and you actually
engage their their ad platform it is um
it just feels extremely
like
really orwellian and freakishly granular
you know you can kind of drill down into
you know people between the age of 22
and 25 and a half who you know uh like
chicken and have been to one art museum
in the last year and um you know you can
kind of hit these demographics that are
just insanely
tight which are it's it's it's pretty
cool
um
there's all sorts of privacy
implications of course but it's it's
kind of interesting um
so facebook for me i've never i've never
really uh used that much
for drumming up kind of interest
in in my projects we used it a little
bit for art space tokyo and i know that
we had
um quite a few
followers maybe five i guess it was
about five or six hundred you know i
mean for a book like art space tokens so
uh it's so niche and so esoteric you
know it's like not only is it about city
that very few people get a chance to go
to but it's about kind of the art world
within that city which is even smaller
subset of um of people so you know it's
it's a very small audience for for a
project like that um
and uh you know we we had a facebook
page and i remember we emailed them a
few times and it drummed up a little bit
of of
of a response but
mainly twitter
and and you kind of have to be a little
bit obnoxious and kind of post i
remember being very aware of like how
many times i was posting to twitter in
in uh may last year i was like trying
not to be that guy who just kind of
spammed his twitter account constantly
but uh twitter you know uh
for me has been great
um
and uh actually mailing lists have been
great too just email blasts yeah you
know i mean just you know you've
the networks have built up over the
years you know collecting
thousands of name cards um
kind of just hitting those design
communities in the in the tokyo
communities and the art communities uh
through that has actually that was
actually very powerful too in the aim of
not trying to be that guy who you know
spams everybody what percentage do you
place
on putting out superior content like you
do versus the energy you put into social
media i mean you hit up the bloggers you
have the twitter and then sort of the
web crawlers you know
see your different tags and and get all
that out there are you just mainly
focusing on the content and
oh you i mean you have to i mean if you
don't have
i mean what what are you know what's 10
000 twitter followers if if you have
nothing to say sure okay um you know and
and
to get you know i think really the trick
with twitter too is you don't
want
50 000
random people following you want a
thousand or two thousand or three
thousand people who
really really really care about what
you're doing right um who are deeply
invested in in in the conversation
you're trying to have
uh it's kind of funny you know i have a
few friends who are on the
uh the recommended twitter lists so for
a while there whenever you when anyone
knew joined twitter they kind of just
got this like default list of people
right that they were like automatically
following yeah um a couple of my friends
around that and they have like you know
i don't know 150 000 followers or 300
000 followers um and in a way it's it's
uh
you know it's like it's i think that
there's a powerful thing when you go to
someone's account you see oh they're
only following 200 people but they have
300 000 followers they must be important
um which is
true but at the same time those 300 000
followers for
for them um
there's no way of knowing actually what
like their real
uh follower count is if that makes sense
sure because it's like it's maybe 295
um
sort of inactive accounts or
random people who followed them because
it was a default
and i think that kind of actually hurts
your ability to kind of
understand whether or not what you're
saying is really resonating with your
community or with your with your
following um
and it kind of removes a little bit of
the
uh the genuineness of that metric you
know
um but fundamentally i mean if you're
not if yeah you know i mean for me it's
all about
if you're not putting out nourishing
content if you're not if you're not
creating good conversation then i mean
yeah
the followers really
you're just kind of doing a disservice
to the people who are who are following
um what you're doing we are on the line
with author designer and developer craig
modd see his work at
craigmod.com
follow him on twitter craig or i should
say at craigmod um craig
one subject that filmmakers have to
complement or i'm sorry contemplate
these days
is do they go the route of the
traditional distributor you know
especially for our realm
of the micro budget filmmaker you know
or these smaller films that don't
necessarily have any any big stars or
names attached
you know we're in a position where we
we're gonna we're gonna you're gonna
give away your rights to your film for
10 or 20 years
and best case scenario oftentimes is
when the money actually trickles back to
the filmmaker you're looking at maybe
twenty five fifty thousand dollars as
the payout for for that term of lease
you know what about this sort of
scenario in the publishing realm is it
becoming a more favorable thing for
authors to consider
self-publishing and sort of going direct
to the con you know direct to consumer
routes such as
um i don't know you know sort of with
the emergence of e-books and
crowdfunding the way you have can can
you sort of shine a light
on us um in regards to um
this in the publishing world
yeah well i mean i think you know let me
just predicate it by saying i
i i know nothing about the film world
i uh
i love i love film but i it's total
mystery how how movies get made um
uh i've read uh you know sydney
lumiere's uh
um you know making film that is a
seminal book on film but
aside from that it's it's a it's a huge
mystery um
but as uh in terms of publishing
yeah i mean right now obviously it's
we're in this we're in the space where
within the next few years a lot of these
systems around which
publishing occurs are going to be
changing tools are going to be emerging
to help
not only
authors write and connect with audience
but
to streamline the process of you know
the production process
and then um
after the after the book is done to
um sort of cultivate
good conversation around around the
objects around around the writing
um
but right now i mean that it's you know
it's it's just
this interesting dichotomy of like do
you go to the traditional publisher now
or do you do it on your own
and
you know i mean
i'm always i'm always talking about
go out there on your own you know sort
of push push forward on your own i mean
with art space tokyo for example we made
uh more doing that kickstarter project
um and then the book sales for the first
month made more
than that book made for the entire run
um
with the the uh with the previous
publisher
um
so i mean there is there is absolutely
the opportunity to make
significantly more money
going with either a much smaller sort of
publishing startup
uh or self-publishing
and now i mean the problem with
self-publishing the problem with
physical books is that you have to
understand how physical books are made
and you have to understand the
production process and distribution is
obviously a pain right i mean this is
kind of the biggest one of the biggest
expenses for all newspapers is um is
actually fuel costs so you know i mean
shipping books around is is a
non-trivial matter and fulfillment is a
non-trivial matter
but thankfully i mean we're moving into
such a kindle
amazon just recently announced that
they're selling more kindle books and
they are physical books
i know that my habits too like i will
only buy
design books or out of print books or
collectible books in physical form now
and if you put out a novel or um
you know there's a nonfiction
book that doesn't have a kindle edition
i
probably won't buy it like it's at that
point now where i just i don't want more
throwaway books in my house you know i
just want uh the content and i also am
addicted to
the highlighting and the note-taking and
it feels
um it feel i feel very
actual reverse i feel lack of intimacy
now when i go back to a printed book
that is just sort of a formless content
printed book
but
the production process is difficult but
you can align yourself with
i think
some of these publishing upstarts for
example
um let's do some examples here we have
uh uh you know a book apart uh jeffrey
zellman jason santamaria mandy brown um
so they started this imprint a year ago
based off of their alistar part um
community
they've been running the alistar part
web magazine about web design for the
last you know decade or so and
they were able to transfer that into a
book publishing arm
and
i don't have the exact numbers but they
made a hundred thousand dollars in
profit in within like two months right
and they were doing a 50 50 split with
the with the author so
go around and talk to authors and and
and ask what
traditional publishing houses are
offering for advances and
if you're doing if you're a first-time
author you're not going to get anything
near 50 000
and you're also not going to see
royalties for
a year until after you know the book is
out if you see royalties at all
so to have
an upstart their first book
be able to make a hundred thousand
dollars in two months
um and they knew nothing about the
production process i mean they were just
kind of learning on the fly they just
they said we're going to figure this out
we're going to learn how to make these
books we're going to figure out the the
distribution of fulfillment
and um
they put together the a great little
team it's just three people
um and
they're able to get an author fifty
thousand dollars uh in two months it's
that's a phenomenal that's i you can't
overstate the the
how different that is
from where indie publishing was three
years ago um that's one example another
example uh amanda hawking she's been
she's kind of popped up in the news
a few times she's i think she's about
20. she's like 26 or something like that
um she's written the my blood approves
uh series
and she sold a million a million books
in the last year wow um at a couple
bucks a pop and you know getting
70 of that that cover price
and um
that's just
off of her
blog basically she built up that
following on her blog by giving away
content for free
and then transferring it into um
you know into sort of full-blown kindle
editions
and uh that's amazing the interesting
thing with her too now is that she's
actually i think she just signed on with
uh actually a big publishing house
and so
there's kind of that there's like this
sort of line i think where
actually if you have the clout and and a
a publisher is willing to give you a you
know two million dollar advance or
whatever i think tim ferriss got you
know several million dollar advance for
his you know four hour body book nice um
then that probably
in that context that probably makes
sense to go with a big guy and then you
don't they're gonna support you more
they're gonna they're gonna invest more
in in your marketing they're gonna
invest more in making sure that that
book
does really well because that's kind of
that's also the thing that most authors
don't understand and they're i
constantly hear
the shock of first-time authors that you
know they get a book deal with the
publisher
and
uh they go through the editorial process
and they go through the production
process and the book comes out and then
nothing the publisher just kind of
leaves them hanging they go
you know time and time again you know
that they the author has had to
put together their book events they've
had to hound the publisher to get comp
copies sent to uh important journalists
they have had to do all of the marketing
they've had to draw you know bang the
drum themselves
and um
all the while not really getting much
money and not really getting a a
a good cut from from the sales
and i think it's a shock you know we
kind of have this fantasy of you know
you sign with a big publisher
everything's going to take care of
itself but that's just the reality is
that's absolutely not the case um
so you know if you're selling a middle a
million books on the kindle platform and
someone offers you a massive contract uh
and is going to like coddle you and kind
of take care of a lot of stuff and you
can just focus on the writing then
which i think you know amanda had kind
of become overwhelmed with the amount of
marketing that she had to do and the
self-promotion she had to do and kind of
managing uh you know the brand that that
she had become
in that context then it probably makes a
lot of sense to go with a massive
publisher but if
you have a niche audience and and
imagine that this the same sentiment can
apply to film if you have a niche
audience of 10 000 or 20 000 people or
50 000 people um you know i love
typography is a wonderful blog that
um
uh sort of exploded i remember you know
john uh you know the the
proprietor of that site
you know he came out of nowhere but he
was writing with so so much passion
about typography um that i remember
within like a couple months he had like
20 000 or 30 000 rss subscribers
um so take a guy like that who's built
up you know 100 000 person base over the
last year and a half
he's doing the codex
publication now
that the first the first issue is coming
out um i think in about a month
um
and
i think that's going to make him a lot
of money
i think that's going to make
the people who are involved with that
project a lot of money and obviously
you're not doing that to make a lot of
money necessarily
but the fact of the matter is is that
that can become a very sustainable thing
when you have a community of
10 20 30 40 50 000 people that are
interested in your voice and interested
in the stories that you're telling um
you can smartly
produce
publications produce films that play to
that community uh
and i
believe and i've seen it time and time
again those publications and those
activities can be uh profitable in in
ways that indie publishing has never
been
profitable before
we had a question just come in from our
listener sherry candler from
sherrykandler.com
and she writes i really love what craig
has to say about ebooks given that i'm
participating in writing a digital book
myself
does craig think there is a
technological reason why more can't be
done with digital books especially the
networking or social reading features
or is it that platforms are waiting for
more demand from consumers to make these
excuse me technical abilities available
i have asked our developer to include
more social interactions with our book
but i'm told there is no outlet to feed
the interactions to like facebook slash
twitter no place to send or store reader
bookmarks so that they can be seen by
all readers seems disappointing to me
yeah yeah no that's
that is i mean
that's the question we're all asking
right now it's like what you know where
where is this social component going to
be
um going to manifest
in um in ebooks
what form is it going to take
um
i think
there's a couple points happening there
number one is that
the the platforms are just they're still
really young
and that
really we're trying to figure out first
of all what's the form of these
of e-books so we'll take e-books for
example what's what's the form that
e-books are going to take in terms of
distribution in terms of format um in
terms of uh
sort of
uh
device i guess you know ipad or kindle
or nook
um right now so you're watching you're
seeing the markets kind of
move back and forth
and try to settle
in a position where you can go okay now
the kindle is is a really viable
platform this is a platform that's going
to be around for a while
let's start investing in thinking about
um what kind of social engagement uh
tools we can build atop that
and so you have guys like um
james bridle uh of booktube.org uh who's
just this wonderful thinker about uh
sort of a futurist and literalist and
and wine sort of obsessive about uh the
future of books and the future of
publishing and he has kind of spear
tried to spearhead this conversation
through a project called open bookmarks
you can go to openbookmarks.org org and
that's where
you know this discussion around what
does that protocol look like that allows
for
platform-independent um conversations to
emerge around
books but you know obviously not just
books but long-form journalism and uh
sort of short short stories and shorter
pieces like that fortune piece that was
published about apple a couple weeks ago
that was initially only available on
their ipad app i think and then they did
a kindle edition of it
um that sold really well uh like a 99
kindle edition of that that one article
um and so how do you allow like those
two different independent platforms to
communicate what's what does that
protocol look like um in terms of the
social layer um
so i think you know
it's it's a it's a combination of things
it's a combination of publishers kind of
just being totally freaked out right now
and trying to figure out how do we make
money is this going to make money how do
we save our business um there's one side
of it the platform's kind of trying to
find
a comfortable space within the
publishing ecosystem it seems like
kindle is really emerging as as the
leader mainly because amazon is doing
such a great job
sort of innovating in that space far
better than
um
in terms of
social
layers specifically far better than
ibooks for example which has no social
layer um kindle is very fascinating uh
and i i mean i think if anyone has any
interest in this space you should
absolutely own a physical kindle um just
just to
engage that technology but amazon has
you know with the kindle platform
they've built user profiles so i have a
kindle profile you can go on there you
can see all of my notes you can see all
of my highlights from from my books and
effectively what we're doing is we're
kind of building a
a networked commonplace book
um the commonplace book uh being this
sort of old um
uh you know this book from the the
1700s um
where um you know mid-seven the
commonplace books were existed in the
17th century you know where you had this
notebook where you would write down
comments and quotes and
thoughts about all of the
the books that you were reading it'd be
this collection of all of your thoughts
effectively and it would be all of the
marginalia that you'd collect along the
way
of engaging physical books in one space
and you know amazon is kind of doing
this with the kindle platform and with
our profiles
um so
while
i think on a
on a larger scale the conversation and
the tools definitely aren't there aren't
the aren't the place that we want them
to be uh
you know in the social engagement sphere
like you know
having the conversations around the
books around sections of the books um
it's not quite there yet
but kindle is definitely making strides
to at least build and and infrastructure
it's probably going to be a closed
infrastructure um which is why it's
important for us to figure out what
these protocols are going to look like
and to create um
hooks sort of beyond the book uh on
other platforms so for example uh kindle
is one it's kind of it's it's a fairly
closed system but epub uh the epub 3
spec includes a lot of um
sort of java javascript compatibility a
lot of html it's effectively an html5
css3 manifestation uh in in the epub uh
within the epub space
and so there's a lot of promise there
where
if epub suddenly allows for
certain javascript hooks outside of
the book so if you're in ibooks and
you're reading an epub file and there
are
hooks within that book to
some sort of centralized
server that sort of is your commonplace
book uh that's platform independent and
can be sort of activated through
javascript calls then
that is a very viable platform
independent uh way of creating a social
layer whether or not ibooks will allow
those calls to happen um whether or not
other ebook readers will allow those
calls to happen because there's a whole
bunch of security implications uh that
arise when you start doing things like
that
we're gonna have to wait and see but we
also as
developers and publishers we also have
to present compelling reasons to open up
um those channels to
folks like the ibooks team at apple so
it's it's this is absolutely the most
interesting space uh i think over the
next couple of years uh within within
the ebook world past we had so many more
questions we wanted to talk to you about
flipboard we want to talk to you about
m.c hammer hanging out at these startups
in the bay area
and his beautiful signature um but
regrettably we do have to end but we
want to thank you so much for your time
craig thank you thank you we've really
enjoyed it yeah i mean this has been
phenomenal
you've blown us away here craig i
believe you know our audience you know
we can see that they're loving it
and just on a personal um note i just
want to mention that they're sort of
just getting into what you do you know
exploring what you have there
at your website craigmod.com and just
seeing you know just seeing that the
combination
of design and layout and content it's
just really
really inspiring and it's inviting yeah
and i just want to thank you you know
because you you really
have you know you're sort of challenging
me you know and challenging me and and
inspiring me at the same time you know
i'm just grateful for it well thank you
guys that means a lot to hear that thank
you and we've been speaking with writer
photographer publisher designer and
developer craig modd for more on craig
please visit craigmod.com
at craigmod on twitter and to put did i
say that right teapeth.com and it's
tputh.com
and also by visiting his work at
flipboard.com thank you again craig for
your time today and for all your wisdom
and and we've really enjoyed speaking
with you
my pleasure thank you guys
and we will return here next sunday on
latalkradio.com
and we will speak with the awesome nadia
g from the cooking channel's bitchin
kitchen nadia g is a chef and tv
personality described by some as the
punk rock julia child you can find out
more about nadia g by visiting bitchin
lifestyle dot tv
do i get to say in kitchen
is that all right
that was used on film courage i like
that uh also many thanks to our guy
ronan rosner here at la talk radio you
know he's just right on the other side
of this room here we love him um he's
the guy behind filmcurse.com
um he's he's missing it all together
but until next sunday have a great week